[Music]
likes fight in this room this room was
not designed to have four people
sleeping in it you haven't done anything
wrong
this is the front line of Britain's
housing crisis nighttime raids in
Barking and Dagenham house checks to
combat an overcrowding epidemic many
people living in the process so they
just need to find out exactly what is
happening fine in this room upstairs
every inch of space converted into
sleeping quarters so based on our
assessment today we can say confidently
about 16 people using this process 16
people and how many bedrooms in total we
have legally we have four bedrooms it's
more than what need licensed recommended
at the next property we meet a family
from Romania all for living cooking
eating in one through to family we
took it and then how much money 600 just
you came here because you wanted to work
to find a job to make money to make a
life here because in my country my son
is better at school large brothers here
it's very important to you where you
live does it matter
yes yes but we used to it here in one
room because we said now it's the only
temporary and we are getting out of here
so that's the dream in our father
[Music]
too many people not enough homes this is
the story we're told about this
country's housing crisis of which this
is a brutal example overcrowding massive
demand for housing high costs pushing
people to extremes and yes our research
has found that a shortage of new homes
is a serious problem in places like
Barking and Dagenham the politicians
answer build more homes hundreds of
thousands of them but what if that isn't
a silver bullet
I've been reporting on the housing
market for a decade and a half now and
the more I've traveled the more I've
realized that that simple story that
we've been told isn't quite right what
if there isn't a single nationwide
housing crisis but multiple different
crises spread across the country so I'm
on a journey to find out this is the
real story of Britain's housing market a
country of too few homes and too many a
country where some homes are too big and
others are too decrepit a country where
the problem isn't that we need to build
more homes in some places we've built
market forces define and sheep the lined
Newcomb nook rules and fail with SEC on
guns
condemned DD a slow and lingering death
Thatcher's Sharda fail across the police
and folk moved soothe while they could
fend the what
this is Newcomb nook in East Asia home
to Rob Wilson an ex miner turned poet
once a thriving coal mining town it is
now quite literally shrinking
the second crisis in the UK housing
market is not about too much demand for
housing but too little
and lack of demands due to weak local
economies is a problem across swaths of
the country particularly in Wales
Northern Ireland the north of England
and here in southwest Scotland what 200
houses have disappeared from the
landscape here Rab is the man who stayed
behind he watched as everyone else left
and as thriving estates like the one on
this hill was simply a raised so Rob
talk us through what would have been
here 10 20 years ago
well what would have been surrounded the
houses here so this would have been like
an alleyway between Hertha's room yeah
just a shortcut and the most people
would have been employed in the main and
industry at that time factories went the
jobs whence and then eventually the
houses yes now it's a bit that's a bit
the story of of nukem Loch Ness earlier
pretty much a ghost town just the ghosts
of old men awesome-looking what we've
got here you wouldn't really just have
the sense that what we need desperately
in all parts of the UK is more housing
well certainly not here right now
in neucom nook and this story is not
over yet this row of houses has been
marked for demolition boarded up
evacuated all except for one home at the
very end of the terrace how long have
you lived there for and he's had been 27
years 27 years on on this in this house
or on the street and that's cute and
they were the last the last man standing
it's how does that feel
a few exciting because of the skin
Kanazawa get people stayed here hmm
and just look the way it is I stopped
coming here what one resilient hump tear
house because you just don't know don't
care how safe you have you kind of
invested a lot of both emotion and time
in your house I have what the nurse's
and just bolt on both of ninh client
what is it what does it mean to you this
house these are maybe zona this is a
housing crisis but it's not the one you
hear about in London nor is it the only
issue
what if writtens problem wasn't too few
homes but the way they're distributed
actually if you counted up all the
bedrooms across the UK and distributed
them between everyone who needed them
there be enough room for everyone but in
reality some houses have more bedrooms
than the residents need in few places is
that mismatched more extreme than here
in Stratford upon this my little baby
we went down to Steinway and I said I'd
like a piano
I will come this way this is our
Steinway Boston and it's got the disc
wavier in it and this is what it does
you don't have to wind it up
I'm 64 years old
I lived in stratford-on-avon the kids
now left home so we got a 5 bedroomed
house just a bit two of us and there's
lots more Peters in towns like
stratford-upon-avon retirees who love
their family home and he weren't quite
ready to give it up this is where we
have all the Christmas parties this is
where we eat primarily as a family
through here is the family room this is
where we spend most of it most of the
times this is your cosy room this is the
cozy room through here is my office a
bit of a mess dear I felt guilty about
taking up lots of space given that
there's a lot of people in the country
who are who are kind of desperate for
more space themselves guilty I don't
think guilt is the word why would I feel
guilty for working hard from since I was
15 years old
downsizing is on the cards I would do it
I'll do it tomorrow
but my wife said no no I'm too young I'm
too young to do that you know and it's
not just an economic decision is it no
no it's a family decision I mean my boy
said dad there's no way you're selling
this house this is this is our house and
home
in life people say all you're lucky yes
look does play a part but it's hard work
right so that's three crises like if
supply lack of demand and under
occupation in place like Stratford but
there's also another problem too this
fourth crisis is that much of Britain's
housing stock simply isn't fit to live
in and when it comes to housing quality
according to our research no other city
has as big a problem as
[Music]
a tale of two cities smart developments
and decaying houses glossy new
apartments and old homes plagued with
problems
[Music]
this is Paula and for those who live in
some parts of Liverpool hers will be a
familiar story five properties in
Liverpool in the last five years
each one of had major problems first us
actually got bit by cat fleas in that
house the second house had gotten
cover-ups they poisoned the gas check
before we moved in the third house the
ceiling coming in the back room the
kitchen the fourth house was sewage in
the garden so will it be fifth time
lucky
Paula took us for a tour to find out
it's no liner on the floor the cold
water tap wasn't working it was this
like this when he arrives yeah these are
just the bare floor board yeah so this
is the kitchen it's quite small miss all
these flies come in from out the sign
I've got like a fly spray got a flight
curtain on why are there so many flies I
don't know you think it's kind of
there's a very Liverpool specific thing
here as they're there just the housing
here isn't isn't as good so I've been
used to my confession of living poor man
I'm not I'm not gonna use this other
house never before hmm at all and it
makes you feel depressed what you want
is to be able to have a house where you
can feel safe a family home that's all I
ask you know one to feel settled
somewhere I just can't feel settled
Cheryl lives in a housing association
property on the other side of town but
she's struggling with the same problems
this is the yard space that leads onto
the entry for the bins
smelled mattress how long has that been
there for two or three months
I mean overnight time is the worst time
for the rats you can see them it's got
me around attacking the bin bags well
there is always a fear that those rats
will then come into the yard and don't
want that around my kids you must have
been pretty shocked by it from the very
start shocked is another suit you can
see there where just showed you with the
paint on the bathroom all they did was
paint over it a few months ago she found
herself homeless after breaking up with
her partner even with two young children
she effectively had no choice over where
to live in a city where so many houses
are old and in disrepair you're not
allowed to view the property you're not
allowed to know what number the property
is you're just given a street name but I
had to take it because if I didn't they
were discharging from their care and not
give us a property at all do you think
it's right the people are living in
homes there that you wouldn't think was
safe I think the housing association
starts to people living in houses that
aren't safe is you've got a roof over
your head you should be grateful that
we've housed you we're still humans at
the end of day and we still are entitled
to a certain standard of living yeah I
mean I get emotional knowing that this
is what my kids are kind of living in a
minute one thing we've learned from our
journey around the country is that while
there are all these localized housing
crises there's also prevailing issue
which is that house prices have got very
high in this country and people's wages
and their ability to finance them hasn't
necessarily risen in lockstep with them
so a uk-wide problem but beyond London
it's most acute in places like South End
on Sea
brawny was born and bred here now she
works as an estate agent trying to get
other people on the property ladder how
do you feel when someone else is
completing on a property the how are you
feeling as you're looking on I'm always
happy for them there's also that thing
in me where I'm like how much that was
me house prices here particularly high
compared with wages partly because of
second homes and partly because of the
London effect commuters moving out here
to avoid high prices in the capital I
moved out when I was 17 and so I've
always worked always paid my taxes
always done everything I'm supposed to
and and I'm 24 now and I'm still no
closer I feel like I'm no closer to
owning a home it is disheartening it
makes you feel like why am I ever
actually gonna be able to get onto the
property ladder it is a lovely place to
live if you can afford it if you can
afford it yeah she rents a room in the
middle of town but the idea is to buy
with her boyfriend I'm kind of quite
lucky I mean where I can actually still
live at home and it's definitely looking
more like the reality that we're renting
first at 30 before I actually get house
can't imagine getting a place for
another good - I'm saying I'm being
hopeful he's being hopeful I'm being
realistic
so five separate housing crises all
happening in hot spots around the
country all requiring different
solutions but with one common theme we
all just want to find somewhere to call
home what does home mean to you home is
a place of comfort and safety where you
can get in from a hard day open your
door know that that's your place where
you're comfortable and happy
[Music]
I don't get home just to my family just
that
security contentment and happiness
it's where you eat sleep drink and be
merry
all means to me as I can come here from
the walk shut the door Kim Barker Dave
everyone today in the Bakken and I can
say from up here
a Canada